Tom Hardy come on is he not a great
actor he is incredible - I think peaky
blinders is my favorite Tom Hardy
performance
when I was much younger I believed that
we had been visited that's why I made
Close Encounters of the Third Kind
because I was really truly believing
there were so many sightings that
something was happening now with the
invention of the smartphones with
cameras and you know there's actually
seems to be fewer UFO sightings and
there was when there were fewer devices
to capture them I believe that there's
extraterrestrial life I think it's it's
about it abounds in the cosmos it's out
there I really don't know right now how
much of that has ever really come here
to explore this these civilizations here
on earth I used to be a much more
fervent believer when I was younger than
I am today
he gives me the warmest memories only
because that was the film that were I
discovered that I really wanted to have
kids someday I never even thought about
having kids I was having a career
instead of children and working with
drew and Henry and Robert and all day
and all the adults who were also like
kids in that film you know you know um
when I was said goodbye to the cast and
I was very sad and we were all very sad
to be leaving each other and that's
where I realized oh my god I've got to
have my own kids so that movie really
opened up a whole new world of real real
living for me that was the one film that
I've seen more than any of the other
films that I directed was ET because
every one of my kids wanted to see it
and they were always afraid at the
beginning as most kids are because they
don't know what et is and he looks
different and it was it helped to have
dad there sitting next to him you know
telling them was all gonna be okay he's
friendly he's gonna come to Elliott's
house he loves Reese's Pieces
and he doesn't die it's always good to
have them have the filmmaker with them
you know holding them by the hand and
taking them through the story one of my
favorite actors I've ever worked with of
my life is Tom Hanks we've done five
movies together and and they've all been
different
and we've also known each other many
mint years before he worked together on
Saving Private Ryan we were friends
socially and we were neighbors and so
that's been one of the most fulfilling
experiences of my career there's so many
actors I would love to work with Pacino
loved to work with him to Nero I would
love to work with him and I think peaky
blinders is wonderful Tom Hardy come on
is he not a great actor he is incredible
I think peaky blinders is my favor
Tom Hardy performance terrified of
global warming and and the sea levels
rising and coastal cities being flooded
I mean just I'm not speaking now as a
science fiction director I'm speaking
now as a person aware of the science of
global warming and um and so yeah I
think we have to find our voices I think
people have to find their voices but
first they have to believe in the
dangers and once they believe in the
dangers and commit to those beliefs then
we have to all rise up you know
universally to do something about it
even if you don't think anybody will
ever listen to you or your vote counts
or your voice counts it does and I think
the more we can do to get people to
realize that that everybody matters and
together we can make tremendously
positive changes for this world
[Music]
you